[SOUND EFFECT PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: And today
I'm going to be
interviewing Oliver
Chittenden, who
is the founder of Head Talks.
Oliver is, actually,
also the director
of the London Speaker's Bureau,
and he has been for 15 years.
And he lines up speakers with
big government and corporate
events.
So speakers along the lines of--
you've had politicians, prime
ministers, presidents, actors,
actresses, CEOs.
Like that, sort of, top
level keynote speakers.
So you've been doing that
successfully 15 years.
Today Oliver's chance to
speak, and to tell his story.
And the angle, I think,
that's really interesting,
and I think you guys will
understand and relate to,
is the idea, is that we all
show a version of ourselves
to the world, particularly
in our careers.
And there's usually another
story going on underneath.
So in Oliver's case, from
the outside looking in,
he had it all.
He grew up in a castle
in Ireland, right?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Grew up in a castle.
Was educated at Harrow.
Had this fantastic, and
still, very successful career.
He has a beautiful
home in London.
farmhouse in France.
He has a gorgeous wife.
He's very wonderful
and supportive.
He's got a beautiful
little girl.
They have a baby on the
way, due like a month today.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So it's very easy
to hear that story and think,
Oliver's got it going on.
He's really successful.
He's sorted.
but what's really interesting
is the other story, which Oliver
is here to talk about today.
And it's your story,
and your ability
to begin telling your
story really honestly,
and honorably to
people, which was
the beginning of
your own healing
of your own mental
health journey.
And it was the beginning
of Head Talks, which
is his not for profit
online, sort of,
digital platform, where
it's kind of opening up
the conversation
around mental health,
and kind of removing
the stigma that's
attached to mental health.
So shall we get started?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
Definitely.
I'm ready.
That was a amazing introduction.
I'll tell you the real me now.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, go ahead.
Well, when did your journey
with mental health begin?
Where did it begin for you?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
I mean, I was lucky.
I had a pretty
charmed upbringing,
largely due to my mother
remarrying very well.
Actually, my father
was an alcoholic.
So I lost him quite early on.
But nevertheless, I was
brought up in a castle.
And it was very
privileged upbringing.
I had a twin brother.
And we were sent off to
the posh private schools.
And really, I was good
at sports, very sociable.
You know, everything on
paper seemed really well.
And I remember having
actually no sense of fear
leaving school, and for
university, and things like.
That I partied.
And I was naughty.
And I took drugs.
And I did all those
kind of things.
And a lot of us do.
But the key thing was I really
felt the world was my oyster.
And I felt, this is what
I've been brought up to do.
I'm going to go out there
and achieve big things.
And that's how I set
out on my journey.
And it was really, sort of, fast
forwarding to the age of 27.
I'm now 41.
Where, typically with my,
sort of, fighting spirit,
I found myself opening a
new office in Brussels.
I'd established the London
Speaker Bureau in London.
And it was starting to go well.
And I have languages.
So I thought, again
typical of me,
thinking, right,
let's push this.
Let's keep pushing.
Found myself in Brussels opening
up the London Speaker Bureau
office in Brussels.
And I mean, the lead
up to that, there
was no real signs
of mental health.
I mean, I didn't even know
what mental health was,
if I'm honest.
I was brought up in
an environment where
you were seen and not heard.
You didn't talk
about your emotions.
So I had no language,
or no skills.
It just wasn't part
of my vocabulary.
And I remember having a
sort of pinpoint backache.
It was literally one
where I could sort of
put my finger on the pain.
And I was convinced it must be
something structural because I
could so pinpoint this pain.
I went to all sorts
of specialists,
and of course, it was nothing.
At the time I thought
nothing of it.
And then, whilst in Brussels,
and building this business,
I suddenly started getting
hit by these waves of anxiety.
And they literally are waves.
If you imagine the biggest
waves that exist in the world,
those pictures you see of
surfers going on these waves,
it's like being hit
like that all the time.
The best way I can
describe it is it's
a bit like being on an airplane.
And you know when it
suddenly dips down like that,
and your stomach jumps
up into your mouth?
It's like that feeling,
but all the time.
And so it just wears you down,
wears you down, wears you down.
And then the
depression kicks in,
because you've been so worn
down by this constant ravage
of anxiety that just takes
away your confidence,
your sense of self esteem,
your power, really,
your internal power
to try to operate.
And I think, for me, having
been brought up the way I was,
and the way I, sort of, imagined
myself, or perceived myself,
I just couldn't
admit this to anyone.
I was like, all right--
I started self-medicating.
I started taking drugs,
alcohol, anything to,
sort of, bury the pain.
And I just pushed it down.
Pushed it down.
And you know, often I
would go back to London
to see my friends,
and it'd be like,
Oliver's the conquering hero.
26 years old.
Director of a company.
Doing well.
And I didn't let on that there
was this huge internal pain
going on inside me.
And I carried on like
that for quite a while,
until I finally,
sort of, took myself
secretly to a psychiatrist.
And I say secretly,
because I still
think there's a sense that
we failed if we go and see
a therapist today.
There's still that stigma.
It's like, oh, I must have
done something wrong in my life
if I go and see a brain doctor,
let's say, or a psychiatrist,
or a therapist.
And I remember going
to see this guy.
And I'll never forget him.
He made me tick all the boxes.
Back then it was a
tick box scenario where
you filled the question in.
And nowadays I think
about those questions.
And I think most of us would
probably tick all those boxes
even if we were sane.
And he said to me, look, you
need to go to the priory.
You need round the
clock surveillance.
You need a whole army of people.
We'll get you better.
We'll get medication.
All of this.
And then he said
something really powerful,
which at the time I didn't
take on board, which was,
your problem Oliver, is
that you're fighting.
And I looked at him and I
thought, what do you mean?
How can you-- are you telling
me to give up my fight?
I just couldn't
comprehend that logic,
because I'd always been taught
to fight for the things I
wanted in life.
And it was just
not in my DNA to--
I thought, if I give up my
fight I might as well give up
my life, take my life even.
And I ran out of that office.
I booked a ticket to Australia.
Told no one.
And I went on the run.
Literally I call
my year on the run.
And I won't take you into the
whole gory story of the year,
but essentially, it ended
up with me being picked up
off the pavement in Sydney,
and shipped back to England
to a treatment center.
Luckily, for me, I have a
very supportive twin brother.
But also, I still had
insurance from my work,
which was still in place.
I was incredibly lucky.
So I went into a
treatment center.
And I got the treatment
that I needed.
And I was a very good patient.
I really wanted to get better.
And I think there
is this sense of,
you often have to be
brought to your knees
before you actually
ask for help.
But it's actually at that
point of putting your hands up
is when the healing can begin.
And I think today we need
to really think about that.
And focus on this
idea of prevention,
especially with
the young, to stop
getting into this spiral,
which I went through,
because the longer you leave
it, the harder it is to unravel.
And a lot of people
don't make it through.
So that's kind of my journey.
And that was my first
experience with depression,
which came fairly late in
life, actually, age 27.
Often there's a history
up to that point,
from bullying in school,
or other problems at home,
or abuse, or
relationship issues.
But no.
For me, it was a thunderbolt
out of the blue, age 27.
SPEAKER 1: Which you
originally completely ignored.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Then hit rock bottom.
SPEAKER 1: To then go get help.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Correct.
SPEAKER 1: So you had
the help at this clinic.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And at some point
you decided, well I'm OK now.
I don't need help anymore.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
I mean, I did the CBT.
The medication was thrown at me.
That was very much
the standard approach.
And I've now completely changed
my views on treatment services.
I'm not going to go
on about the NHS,
or anything like that today.
But I do feel that
it's very archaic.
It's very in need of innovation.
And there are so many
things that we can do
to feel good about ourselves.
And I think the important
thing to remember
is that we're all
so unique, in terms
of where we get our inspiration
or our sense of recovery from.
It's not a one size
fits all approach.
It's very much a pick and
mix, create your own toolbox.
Find out what works for you
and do those every week.
Like you would go to
the gym to stay fit,
we need to try
and keep this fit.
And there are a lot of practical
things that you can do.
And as the narrative is changing
from one of, kind of, stigma--
which is still there--
I'm hoping we can
now start really
focusing on some of
the practical things,
and the media, that
we can actually
do to stay well, outside just
medication and CBT therapy.
SPEAKER 1: And you're going
to share some of that with us
in a little bit.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: Before we get to
that, so you had the therapy.
You're feeling good.
You took yourself, I
think, off to France.
You wrote two books.
Met your wife, began
having first child.
Everything was
looking really good.
And you felt recovered.
But then what happened?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
So after my first,
kind of, depression, it was
a long journey out of it.
I mean, it's not a light
switch, mental well-being.
And because I'd left it,
and I buried it for so long,
it took that amount
of time to unravel it.
So it's very much a journey
like that out of it.
It's, kind of, building
your mental resilience.
I set myself a good
two years to rebuild.
And there are knocks
on that journey.
But eventually you do
build your resilience up
and you get back to,
sort of, a better place.
But when that happened
I started to take
a bit of a philosophical view
on what had happened to me.
In a way, I think it
made me a more humbler
person, a nicer person,
a more connected person.
I think the relationships
that I have with people
are much more personable,
and much more real,
as a result of it.
So I sort of looked at
it as part of my journey.
It's happened.
But I also knew,
intrinsically from the pain
that I'd suffered--
and they say mental pain is
worse than physical pain.
And I absolutely
agree with that.
I knew intrinsically
that I needed
to change something in my life.
And being me, I
went off to France,
and moved myself to France,
to the middle of nowhere.
At the time they were giving
out mortgages to anyone.
And I was not, despite my
wonderful introduction,
I was not rich, or famous,
or anything like that.
I was pretty ordinary.
But ordinary enough to get
a 90% mortgage from a bank
on a foreign property pre-2008,
which is pretty unbelievable.
And I turned up in this village
in the middle of nowhere,
and settled in.
And my friends were
80, 90-year-olds.
And they were like, what is this
young Englishman doing here?
It's a very strange occurrence.
But it was a very
happy time for me.
Cause I kind of grounded myself.
I re-identified who I was,
and created a new identity
for myself, you know?
And I had a dog.
And I traveled a lot.
I was still working
with my speaker bureau,
but just remotely.
And there were
really good years.
Really great years.
I got married.
I had a little girl.
And we were living
the French life.
And in many ways I'd
forgotten about my depression.
And I definitely wasn't every
day using the tools that
I'd, perhaps, learnt in my
first instance with depression.
And about 10 years later--
I also wrote some books.
And I've only had two big
episodes of depression.
But something positive seems to
have come out of both of them.
And definitely getting
married, and moving to France,
and writing a couple of books.
I did one book on
inspiration, and tried
to understand what
it is that inspires
people, rather than just talk
about their amazing stories.
Actually try and
understand where
their inspiration came from.
And that was a real
passion project,
as is Head Talks, which
I'll talk about in a minute.
And yeah, I remember
just one day.
I remember it
very, very clearly.
A beautiful sunny day in France.
And I was saying
goodbye to my wife.
And she had a friend
staying with her.
And I went to England.
And it was to a funeral,
so not the nicest
of situations to go to.
But bang, I was triggered.
I was back in the panic attacks.
I was back into that anxiety.
And I was like, whoa,
where did this come from?
It was just like a sledgehammer.
And I just couldn't believe.
And I hoped that it would
just pause, at the start.
And I tried to start
remembering my tools, and some
of the therapy.
And it didn't.
And it got worse and worse.
And I struggled and struggled.
And--
SPEAKER 1: That must have
felt really devastating,
when it felt healed,
and then be--
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: It was.
It was really horrible.
And I've learned now
that a lot of people
misinterpret mental illness,
in the sense that you just
drop into a hole, and
pop out the other side.
It's often a lifetime
of careful management
to keep the so-called
black dog at the back door.
Not let him in.
And it's a big
misconception that people
have about mental illness.
But lo and behold I
really realized that when
it hits again, often it is
harder than the first time,
even though you can't imagine
it could be any worse.
And I was so upset.
I was so angry.
I wasn't on my own in my life.
I had responsibilities.
I had a child who
was in a school.
I had a wife who didn't speak
French who I needed support.
We were in the
middle of nowhere.
It wasn't like I could just
up and go somewhere else.
And so those pressures were
a lot harder to live with,
whilst being not well.
And I was never someone who was
totally crippled by depression.
When I was under
my duvet every day
I was always able to operate.
That was, kind of, my fighting
spirit, if you like, as well.
And I did therapy.
I did Skype therapy.
I thought, have I
missed something here?
Is there some trauma from my
past that I haven't dealt with?
And I did the therapy.
And I did all of this.
And it went on for a
good year and a half.
And we decided to
move back to London.
And it was at that point where
I, sort of, took quite a rash
call.
And I thought, I really want to
throw the kitchen sink at this,
and just break this pain
that was living with me.
And I took myself
off to the states.
I no longer had
health insurance.
And with health insurance,
another big problem
is if you're lucky enough
to afford private health
insurance, the minute you claim
some sort of mental health
issue you're
blacklisted completely.
So there's a whole,
sort of, fight
that needs to happen there.
But I decided that I would
take myself off to the states.
SPEAKER 1: When you took
yourself to the states,
did this feel like,
this is my last ditch--
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Effort?
I feel like I've
tried everything.
I've done everything.
It's not working.
This has to work.
Did it feel like all or nothing?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
Definitely.
I mean, again, it's
typical of my character
to do an all or
nothing approach.
And I just wanted to throw
the kitchen sink at it,
and just see if I
could do something
to try and break this pattern.
And it was probably
quite foolish
and not thought out properly.
But I clinged on to this.
Through my speaking
activities I know
about this lady called
Brene Brown, who
is one of the most
viewed TED Speakers.
She's basically the, sort
of, guru on vulnerability.
And I really recommend her
books, actually, and at least
watching her TED talk.
And I saw that she was
running a workshop.
She runs workshops in Tennessee.
She's based at
Dallas University.
I thought, right, well
I'm going to go for it.
I'm going to go out there.
And I'm going to go on
this vulnerability journey,
and expose my pain.
She talks about
leaning into the pain.
And I thought, well, I'm
as vulnerable as I can be.
So I'll just go for it.
And I went out there.
And it was hard for
my wife to see me go.
But I wanted to do. it.
I wanted to get away.
Save them the pain of seeing
me how I was, and try it out.
So it was 30 days.
And it was intense, as
Americans are quite intense.
Very process driven.
No phones.
No TV.
It was quite holistic,
which I quite liked as well.
But what happened during
that period of time
was I got very ill
physically, as well.
So I was ill mentally.
And my organs started
shutting down on me.
And it started with my kidney.
And then my bladder,
my liver, my prostate.
And I ended up in hospital
in Nashville really,
really properly ill.
And it was just very, very hard.
I was my own.
But I remember thinking to
myself on that hospital bed,
I remember thinking,
maybe, just maybe this
is what it's going to
take to break this.
I was like, bring it on.
Let's see.
SPEAKER 1: You body's, like,
your last line of defense,
isn't it?
And it's almost
like if you're not
listening to where
your healing is--
and I know we're going to
get on to this in a second.
But if you're not
really listening
to what you need to heal
your body is going to go,
right, you know what?
I'm going to shut down.
And then maybe
you'll listen to me.
Maybe then you'll
take this seriously.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: I was
so caught up in my head
that I wasn't
listening to my body.
And I think, looking back on
it, it was my body's reaction
to that, kind of, holding
on, for those years.
It was like, now,
just let it go.
And I cried, and I cried.
I learnt how to cry.
I've never cried, really.
In my life.
And now it's a major
part of my own toolbox.
It's actually a really
important part of my toolbox.
I get a huge, sort of,
release of anxiety, and pain.
And I find it very helpful.
I think having been very
sort of, blokish, I call it
my man cry.
In fact, the louder it gets,
the better the healing.
SPEAKER 1: Totally.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
So yeah I did that.
But again, I think at that
time, and that experience,
and coming back to my
family, I was so broken.
I was just so broken literally.
I could hardly talk.
And I was so, so broken.
But I knew, again, at this
time that something good was
going to happen out that.
That something out of the
darkness was going to happen.
And that's really,
kind of, what happens.
Slowly but surely I started
building my mental resilience.
And that's what gave
birth to Head Talks.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, but
what you did was you
went from that
fighting attitude,
all your life fighting,
and striving, and pushing.
And then with managing
your mental health
it was fighting,
striving, pushing
to search for the answer, to get
the solution, to do the work.
And then, I think it's
really interesting, actually,
that you kind of brought
to Brene Brown's work
on vulnerability,
because within that
was a little seed of,
well, maybe that's
where my healing lies.
Maybe it's in being vulnerable
and no longer fighting.
And then when your
body totally shut down
and you were that sick, you
were utterly vulnerable.
And there was an element
of surrender at that
moment for you, wasn't there?
So you went from really
fighting to, OK, I really
have to surrender now.
And I think, within the
surrender was your freedom.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Definitely.
SPEAKER 1: And your healing.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Absolutely.
I think acceptance, for
me, was such a key word.
I was no longer fighting.
I accepted that
this was something
that I would have to manage.
It could become
again in my life,
in 10 years, three
years, two years.
But it was something I had to
accept, rather than push away.
And it remains a really
key point in my recovery,
and in my toolbox.
So that when I do
get anxious or I do
feel depressed, rather
than just pushing it away,
I just kind of accept it.
I don't resist.
And I think that's
really, really important.
Just to always use the--
I have various analogies.
But it's like the bus analogy.
It's like, as long as
I'm driving the bus,
all the emotions
can be passengers.
And they might try and get
to the front and drive it.
But I'm in charge.
And they can come,
and flow in, flow out.
But yeah, acceptance
was very key for me.
SPEAKER 1: And I've
heard you talk about-- it
was your crucible moment.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
It was.
I mean, in many
ways it was like,
something's got to change.
I think, you know, we all
get a big, big kind of,
wake up call when we get ill.
Whether it's an illness, or
an accident, or something
like that.
Something profoundly
changes in us.
I've seen it in a lot of people.
And for me, I didn't quite
know what it would be.
But I knew something
would change.
SPEAKER 1: So I thank god for
the journey that you've had,
because at every stage
of it you learned
different ways of coping
with your own mental health.
And through that, you
created your own toolbox.
And we're going to get
to that in a minute.
But through it you
realized-- and this
is what so powerful
about your story,
and what you're doing
now with Head Talks.
You realized that mental
health isn't a one stop shop.
It's like, there's not
one fix for everybody.
You have to create
your own toolkit.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: That's it.
Definitely.
And I learn, and
I'm still learning.
I still learn.
And one of the beauties of the
journey I'm on with Head Talks
is I'm interviewing so many
different types of people.
And I was interviewing a guy
who's a specialist on, kind of,
the impact of cold water on your
mental health, arctic water.
Swimming clubs are swelling
up around the country.
And it comes from
Scandinavia and Switzerland.
And it's great to
try these things out.
And I'm trying to create
this platform so that people
can have access to some of the
practical things we can do,
because yes, I passionately
believe that this idea that you
can just address mental health
with meditation and CBT, which
is what we're
getting from the NHS.
It's just not the
right approach.
We need to be offering a
lot more variety, in terms
of what you can
do, because you can
get as much inspirational
sense of recovery
from singing in your
local choir than you can
from taking a pill.
It might be swimming in the cold
ocean, acupuncture, something
more holistic, like
yoga or meditation.
There are lots and lots
of things you can do,
and it's about holding onto the
things that make you feel good,
and adding them to your
toolbox, because quite frankly,
we all need a toolbox in 2017.
It's chaos out there.
The digital world,
you guys know about.
It's overwhelming.
We need to think about this.
It almost feels like
we've gone into battle.
We've, kind of,
innovated and we've
gone so far down that journey.
And we've dealt with the body.
But we've kind of--
haven't had a plan
B for the mind.
We've kind of forgotten
about the mind.
And the mind is what makes you
the best version of yourself.
It's the thing that gives you
the best experiences, the best
relationships, friendships.
If you're in a good
state mentally,
all those things are
going to be better.
So yeah, I've got lots of views.
And I can go on and on.
But I'd love to show the
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, why
don't we take a look at--
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
The show reel--
SPEAKER 1: The show reel.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Just to
give you a sense of Head
Talks, and the
journey I've been on.
SPEAKER 3: My 13th birthday I
thought that I would actually
go out and give myself a
birthday present that I wanted.
And that was the
first time I had sex,
at 13 with a 26-year-old man.
And I didn't realize
that was abuse.
SPEAKER 4: I didn't
have any alcohol.
I didn't have any drugs.
I didn't have any
means of numbing
that anxiety, and that
pain, and that adrenalin
that I was feeling at the time.
And I took a knife and
I cut my chest open.
SPEAKER 5: It was like
everybody in your life
that you loved had
suddenly all been killed.
And that was it.
And it was like the
world had almost ended.
SPEAKER 6: It's a car crash.
It's going through
the windscreen
and lying in the middle
of the motorway, not sure
if you can move your limbs.
SPEAKER 7: I
actually totally had
come to terms that
it was fine to die.
I just thought, you
know, I've done my best.
Sorry I'm feeling a
bit emotional now.
You know, I've had my children.
They've got each other.
You Know, my husband
can look after them.
Actually, I can't go on.
This pain is just too awful.
SPEAKER 8: And I really
think, looking back on it,
that's really that point
when the recovery started,
because I wasn't
fighting against myself.
SPEAKER 3: I asked
myself a question.
But whose words are they?
And it's like, ah.
Cause they aren't my words.
They are words that were
given to me as a child.
And I realized, if
they're not my words,
then I can stop saying them.
And I stopped saying
them to myself.
SPEAKER 5: It was
through talking
about what I was feeling
that actually helped
me make sense of it, and
turn it into a strength,
as opposed to a weakness.
SPEAKER 9: You've really got
to look behind what's there,
and then create something new.
Hence the need for
acupuncturists,
for yoga, for people
doing EMDR, for rolfing.
For all the things that
people are looking for,
to kind of, cathartically
to get it out.
SPEAKER 10: So
it's the intention
that you put into talking, into
the needle when you apply it
to the body.
SPEAKER 6: If you've got cancer,
and you've had chemotherapy,
and your hair's all
fallen out, and you've
got that, kind of, look that
people have, people look at you
and they know.
And we've developed the
language to deal with that.
But when you walk
down the street,
and you see somebody in
emotional distress, which
I think we see more and more
of, we haven't got the language.
SPEAKER 11: When you start
to talk about these issues
to groups of people
there will be those who
put their hand up and say,
actually, yeah I've felt that,
or I went through that.
And that, actually,
is what Olly's
trying to do with Mind Talks, is
to get people talking about it,
in order to build a community,
to get the issue out there,
and to get people realizing
that there is help,
and there are positive
things you can do.
SPEAKER 12: Well I think this
is a fantastic initiative.
It's all about getting mental
health out into the open.
Normalizing it in a way.
And removing the
mystery, the mistake,
and critically, the stigma.
There's nothing
more that we could
do in society that
could have a bigger
impact on the well-being
of our country,
than if we focus
on mental health,
and stop the neglect
of mentally ill health.
SPEAKER 1: How does
it feel seeing that?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yes--
SPEAKER 1: Do you feel proud?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: I do.
It makes me feel
quite emotional.
And I just think how
brave those people
are to share their story.
But it also, it just amazes
me how much pain is out there,
quite frankly.
It's like if you can create
the environments for people
to share and to be honest with
what's going on in their lives,
it's a real privilege to
be able to have an impact,
and to see that show.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
It's amazing.
So it was a seed of an idea.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And now it's an
up and running, functioning,
changing people's
lives platform.
So can you describe
exactly what it is?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Sure.
So I spent the last
year and a half
going up and down the
country interviewing people.
I really, at the start
I was free styling it.
I self-funded.
Had no real support.
Didn't understand how a
camera worked, or editing,
or anything like that.
And I just went on this journey.
And I wasn't entirely sure where
it was going, if I'm honest.
But I knew that I wanted
to do this visually.
I think there's
so much out there
that is very academic looking,
scientific, very wordy, online.
And especially in alternative
therapies, it's so vast,
and there's no real
leadership in it.
So you can get very lost as
someone who's struggling,
and you can spend a lot of
money, and a lot of time.
And often it can be too
late to get to what's
going to work for you.
So I wanted to try and
create a platform that
brought all of this together in
a, sort of, modern looking way,
in a visual way that people
could communicate easily
via social media.
I was very aware of the young.
And I wanted them to
really understand this.
And to have a website
where you weren't looking
over your shoulder
thinking, god, someone's
going to see me on a
mental health site.
I think the way the website
looks, it's very fresh.
It's just lots of different
people talking about the mind,
really, from different angles.
And it was astonishing how
people would just drop in
with-- and I would be with
academics, scientists, authors,
and people with success stories.
And some, at the end of it
they'd say something like,
yeah, and I spent a
year on the streets,
and my wife committed suicide
then, and that was challenging.
And so everyone's
got their story.
and it was a beautiful journey.
And I think one of the things
that really bounced out at me
was there's a real feeling of
disconnection, in the world,
actually.
The irony being we've
invented the internet
to be more connected.
But actually I don't think we've
ever felt more disconnected.
Add on top of that, this
capitalist drive that
has really had a negative
impact on community where
you can get so much healing.
They've done both on a lot
of good things, the internet,
and capitalism.
But there have been downsides.
And I think mental
health has definitely
suffered as a result of them.
And it was really about giving
access to lots of people,
to lots of different
things that they could do.
Informing them, inspiring
them, and educating people
so that they could
make their own choices,
create their own
Head Talks journey,
and go back into
their community.
And they're going,
ah, I really resonated
with what that guy said,
or what that lady said.
I'm going to try that out.
Or, yeah, that was
really interesting,
using poetry, or gardening,
as my form of therapy.
So I didn't really
know, at the start,
where it was going to go.
But with my experience
with the speaker network
I was able to, sort
of, network quite well.
And it was a, sort of, balancing
act of who to interview,
because although the
big names are good,
because they create
a bit of awareness,
I was very conscious
that I didn't
want to create a, kind of,
bandwagon for celebrities.
I think there is a
danger that depression
is becoming quite cool.
It's like, yeah I'm depressed.
I'm cool.
And I didn't want this
site to be like that.
But at the same time, it
helps draw attention to it.
But I also wanted people
with lived experience.
And actually, now that I'm able
to, sort of, track where people
go, what videos are most
popular, the lived experience
is still really
powerful for people,
because it creates hope, a sense
of community, a sense of I'm
not my own having
these thoughts.
I always say, it's like we all
have, kind of, battlefields
going on in our minds
in some shape or form,
and just being able to
give some air to that.
And lived experience, also where
it's really helpful is that--
I say to people when
I'm interviewing them.
I just say, that tell me
about the darkness, the pain,
and then the journey out.
The tools that worked for you.
And what you're up to now.
And it's the variety
of tools that people
have used, which are
so helpful, because you
can learn from other people.
And if you connect
with them, then you
can try their tools
out, just as you
can try someone who's
a specialist on yoga,
and really focus on yoga.
So it's bringing all of
that together in one place
was what I was
trying to achieve.
But it's very organic.
It's moving.
It needs to be like
that, to, sort of,
go with what people are after.
I mean, I never had
a Facebook page.
I'm coming to the dig--
SPEAKER 1: You still
don't have one?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: No I'm
coming to the digital world
very late on.
But it's a good learning.
It's a great, great
thing for mental--
SPEAKER 1: Olly did his
first Facebook Live today.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
Learning and curiosity are
very, very powerful things
for keeping a healthy mind.
SPEAKER 1: Indeed.
And I've heard it said,
many times actually,
that having your own business
is the best personal development
journey you could ever
take, because you learn
a hell of a lot about
yourself in setting up
your own
entrepreneurial venture.
What have you learned through
setting up Head Talks, which
is such an inspired action?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
I think I'm so
happy to be doing something
I'm really passionate about,
because it means so much to me.
And I think being able
to contribute, as well.
I spent 18 years in
the corporate world.
And you know, even
though The Speaker Bureau
has this, sort of, soft
sounding ring about it,
it's quite a aggressive
world to be in.
Its deal making.
And people are charging
a lot of money,
and are dealing with lots
of crooked politicians
making lots of money.
And I love it.
And it's been great.
And it's still part of my life.
But it's just so refreshing to
be part of my tribe, as well?
I feel like my work is like
linked to my well-being
now, which is a real
relief, to be honest.
And--
SPEAKER 1: Sort of be
able to merge the two.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
And just creating
that community,
and reaching out to people.
And it's been hard.
I mean, you know, I still
have really hard days and.
I don't react well to stress.
And getting something like
this launched is not easy.
There's loads of challenges.
But just keep pushing.
I think when you've
got a passion,
and you're on something, even
if all the walls are coming up,
it's like just a
little window opens up,
and you creep through it,
and you're away again.
It's been great.
The one thing I'm
trying to do now
is just step back and digest
it, and really appreciate
what I'm doing, and kind
of, be present with it,
because there's always so
much to do in a start up.
Especially if you're on
your own, driving at--
SPEAKER 1: Well, you're full
time with the London Speaker
Bureau.
And this is a full time gig now.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah,
it's more full time now.
SPEAKER 1: As well.
So I think that's probably
a nice little lead
into your toolbox,
and how you're
managing your mental health
now, because probably
now more than ever you need it,
and you need to walk your talk.
Live that truth to keep
inspiring other people,
and have this be an
authentic venture.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
Yeah definitely.
SPEAKER 1: So should we
take a look at that--
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: I think--
SPEAKER 1: Slide that
you've got on your end?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
Part of the idea
with Head Talks-- and we're
still in a phase one approach.
And luckily we had funding
from a foundation that's
completely non-profit.
But we're now going to
start going into corporates,
and doing workshops.
But I'm hoping that--
I sort of have this
vision, that there
will be a basket, a
bit like on Amazon,
and you'll be able to
drop your videos into it,
and create your own toolbox.
And we'll be able to actually
give people a real journey
through Head Talks.
But this is what works for me.
I mean you know, as I said
earlier, we're all so unique.
And I think, whether we do it
consciously or unconsciously,
we all do things to
keep us on the level.
Even if we're not
talking mental health.
So I have to go to the
gym on a Monday morning.
That's just something
I really try and do.
I actually need to
go three times a day.
I love kicking the
shit out of a punchbag,
because that releases a lot
of my anxiety and stress.
Good sleep is just crucial.
I stopped drinking last year.
I love wine.
But it just started
affecting my sleep.
And so I just woke up too
many mornings thinking,
I can't feel like this anymore.
So I gave that up.
I'll have a beer
occasionally still.
But you know, the
party days are waning.
I love sunshine, massage, spa.
Those are all luxuries
that I do occasionally.
I meditate every
morning for 20 minutes.
That's something
I do religiously.
Meditation's probably the
biggest gift I've given myself.
And it's not easy to get into.
There's loads of apps.
It's a very personal journey,
like all these things are.
But it's really,
really helped me.
I actually have someone I know,
so I went to various retreats.
And I followed him.
And I have a recording that
I listen to in the morning.
And it's just vital for me.
Allowing myself a man cry.
That's been huge for me.
It's almost like I drop
into like, the victim.
And I say, you know what?
I'm really pissed off.
I'm so fed up with having
to manage this mental health
issue.
And I'll watch a
video of my daughter,
or a really sad talk
on the internet,
or a really sad movie, just to
get, kind of, emotions going.
And then bang I'll let it out.
It sounds a bit
like a machine gun.
And it's brilliant.
And it resets.
Me it just completely resets me.
And I realized that age 40.
Talking, talking,
talking honestly.
I always challenge myself to
be as honest as I possibly can.
And then, obviously,
the mindful thing
is linked to the meditation.
But it is as simple as
recognizing the blossom
out there.
Just stopping, taking a
different route to work.
Just changing things a bit.
I often find having
a cup of tea,
or an apple, or a raise,
just to smother the senses.
You know often, if
you're, kind of,
going round and round in
your head, if you can just
smother one sense--
like, for me, loud music in my
ears can drown out the voices.
Or can buy like eucalyptus,
and you can inhale it.
And just for the sense of smell.
And it just, kind
of, clears the head.
And so there's just
little, sort of,
mindfulness things that I do.
And yeah.
And just exercise is Key
I know everyone says it.
And it's quite boring.
But it really is
very, very important.
So it's not rocket
science, all of it.
But it's what works for me.
But I'm still trying things.
I mean, I was talking
to this cold water guy.
He's been-- for 13 years, he
swims every day in Brighton
in the sea.
And he was telling me
about the community
that meets every day at 7 AM.
It's people with
arthritis, with no legs.
But you know, this cold water
is having a hue impact on them.
And I've been, sort of, looking
up where these outdoor swimming
pools are.
So I'm still learning.
And I still try
things out as well.
SPEAKER 1: What do you think
the most watched video is?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: The most
watched video, I think--
what's been interesting
is the men, actually,
because I think, men,
we've kind of bred this--
historically, the
man's gone out,
and has brought in the food,
and delivered, and gone out
and done the job.
And even we talk
about manning up,
and the man being the
strength in the family.
And I think, you look
at male suicide rates,
and it's really,
really worrying.
I think outside
car crashes, it's
the biggest killer of young
men, because it's hard for a man
to come forward and
talk about his emotions.
And I think there's an amazing
story of Johnny Benjamin, who
is the man on the bridge guy.
I don't know if you
guys know about him.
But he was about to commit
suicide off London Bridge.
And a passer by came and
talked him out of it.
And then he spent--
I can't remember how many years
trying to find the passer by.
And they've linked up now
and they tell their story.
But also really successful
people, like Simon Woodruff,
the founder of Yo sushi.
A millionaire in his own right.
He lives on a houseboat
on the Thames.
Hearing him talk about
how he prays with his wife
every morning by his bed, and
his problems with depression,
and addiction.
Very humbling.
And then, even Nick Love,
who's from a council
estate in the east end who's
quite a big film director.
Who does very hard edge films
on football hooliganism,
and things like that.
And him talking about how
he goes to boxing and just
breaks down in tears
because of this release.
It's very powerful,
those kind of stories.
You have to go and have a look.
I mean, there are lots.
Again, it's unique.
It's like, what does it for you?
The lived experiences
and the ordinary folk,
as well, are equally powerful?
But I hope-- whenever I sit
down with someone I say,
if you want to
swear, cry, laugh.
Just make it real and
take us on that journey.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Yeah.
I find it really, really
touching and very powerful
when you say so,
kind of, casually,
how you'll have a good man
cry, or your need to box,
or you just need
to express emotion,
and how important that is.
I think most men--
I don't know if any men
in the room can relate.
But most men are not OK with
having that conversation,
or even considering
that conversation,
considering being emotional.
So you doing that, I
think, is really important.
Do you wish something like
Head Talks existed for you
about 10 years ago?
Is that a motivation
to create it?
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, god, I was
lucky 10 years ago.
You know, honestly, I
was in such a bad way.
I started on an
addiction unit, because I
was so heavily self-medicating.
And then depression.
I could easily have
died, if I'm honest.
My life could have
not turned around.
The stigma of mental
health was so strong then,
and I had no tools.
And I wish I had been around.
And in fact, on
the stigma thing,
we can actually do a quick
test, because it is still
very, very alive.
If you'd just all like to
stand up, just really quickly.
I know it's boring.
But if you'll all just stand up.
And if you stay
standing, like, if you've
had a mental illness,
or a family member has.
It could be addiction,
bulimia, depression, anxiety.
You know, just stay
standing, basically.
And then I want you to stay
standing if you've actually
been able to talk openly about
having one of these conditions,
or a family member.
SPEAKER 1: If you have
been able to talk about it.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: So actually,
it's quite interesting.
So the stigma is
still very prevalent.
We've, kind of, seen it here.
There is still a stigma
around mental ill health.
And it's not just the
privileged backgrounds.
Sit down everyone.
It's not just a
privileged background.
Factory workers in
the north, they're
not going to go and
tell their bosses,
or their parents about
feeling depressed, and things
like that.
It's across the board.
Winston Churchill,
Abraham Lincoln.
There are many,
many examples of it
from the arts and
things like that.
It is something
that's very prevalent.
SPEAKER 1: That was amazing
only two people weren't
standing at the first question.
Have you ever experienced any
level of mental health issues,
illness?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
I think this is it.
SPEAKER 1: Pretty much the
entire room was standing.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: I think
it's that human condition
thing that we need to realize.
Is that we all have varying
degrees of mental health.
You know, it's like we
mention mental health,
and we almost automatically
think that equals illness.
It's actually not.
It's just different
levels of it.
So if we can learn how to
keep our resilience going,
because there are going to be
challenges in all our lives.
But it's just being able
to lean on the things that
work for us to rebuild
when we need to,
and to be able to
cope in a pretty--
we need to be adapting
with the times.
We've left the mind behind.
SPEAKER 1: So this is
your personal toolbox
but you have a toolbox
to share with everybody.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: This
is just, like, a very--
SPEAKER 1: Overview.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Oh,
this is something I say.
I always say there's
no magic pill,
otherwise I would have found it.
But if you go on
to the next slide.
So again, it's not
complicated stuff.
But it's just things to,
kind of, think about.
You can read that.
SPEAKER 1: Because I
think what you're about,
Oliver, is not having
people hit rock bottom
before they seek help
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
Yeah, I think that's--
SPEAKER 1: I mean,
the reason why
you got Head Talks, the reason
why you're showing this slide,
is because you, kind
of, want people to--
you want to alert them
to getting conscious.
Maybe there's something
on the way for me.
Maybe I'm sliding
down to rock bottom
if I don't do anything about it.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: I
think there's that.
And there's also, actually,
what's interesting,
I think equally
interesting, is actually
I could feel a lot better than
I do if I just try that out.
Like we're sometimes
living on a level.
And we think, oh I'm OK.
I'm all right with this.
But actually, you go and dive
in the Arctic Ocean, and think,
god I feel brilliant.
And you know, you feel 20%.
It's like why wouldn't you--
SPEAKER 1: It's like surviving
to thriving, isn't it?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Like, why not?
It's like why not try
things out that could
make you feel a lot better,
do you know what I mean?
But absolutely, the
prevention thing is key.
And it's a really exciting
time for mental health
now, because the stigma,
the lid is lifting slowly.
But we're just so behind, in
terms of what we give people.
And as I said earlier, it just
needs to be rethought through,
re-innovated.
I mean, you go to the
Scandinavian countries,
and the way they're leading
not only their health services,
but their societies, the focus
is much more on community,
on happiness.
Some countries have
ministers for happiness now.
And I think it's great.
I was actually at a
conference recently
with the former prime
minister of Finland.
A guy called Alex Stubb.
And unlike most other
former prime ministers
he actually will only
speak about happiness.
He doesn't want to
talk about politics.
And it was amazing hearing
him talk about this,
and how this should be
front topic, on the top,
in government.
SPEAKER 1: So what's next?
Where are you taking it now?
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
So, just keep--
SPEAKER 1: What about Q And A.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
Just keep working.
Yeah.
Head Talks is just
going to keep going.
Follow the journey.
We want to take people
on more of a journey.
But if anyone's got any
questions while I'm here,
please feel free to ask
any questions you like.
SPEAKER 1: Do you have
time to ask them now, or--
OLIVER CHITTENDEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's been interesting
hearing about your journey.
And you talked a lot about,
almost over-achievement,
but like, that real pushing.
And I wonder how you
approach your work now, like,
post your healing?
Do you feel that you take
a different approach?
Because I guess there
wasn't lots in your two
books around how you work.
I mean, I've also, kind
of, come from a background
of like working
really crazy hours,
and then from coming to
Google, trying to re-adjust.
But I can still find
I have a tendency
to want to do too much, or
to keep up with my peers.
So I just it'd be
interesting hear
if you've got any tools
around work-life balance.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE] question.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
Yeah no, I mean, I
get caught up in it like
everyone else still.
And I get overwhelmed,
and I get stressed.
And I don't stop enough.
I've learned to, kind of,
digitally detox a little bit.
So I really kind
of set times around
when I turn my phone
off, when I get home,
and when I turn it
on in the morning.
There's actually
some scientific proof
that shows that
dopamine is released
when you receive messages.
You actually feel excited
because someone wants you,
and is like sending messages.
So there's this addiction,
almost like smoking.
And I'm sure they knew
about that before they
invented all these things.
So it's creating some
control over the digital side
of things.
And we've actually done
a talk on digital detox.
Got an expert to
do a talk on that.
And it's just taking
myself out of my head,
and onto the tennis
court, into the spa,
into the gym, spending
time with my family.
But being really disciplined
around the digital, for me,
is massive.
You know, again,
mindfulness, meditation.
That's a really personal
moment of my own to cherish.
Peace and quiet.
Thank you everyone.
I hope you enjoyed that.
SPEAKER 1: I thought we would've
been kicked out of the room.
OLIVER CHITTENDEN:
Have a great day.